بريطانيا ايضا ينفذ موظفون في قسم مراقبه
الجوازات في عده مطارات بريطانيه اضرابا
عن العمل للمطالبه بتحسين ظروف العمل ورفع
الرواتب وقد يواجه الاف المسافرين عبر
مطارات هيثرو
وجاتويك وبرمجام وكارديف ومانشستر
يوناكولا بسبب الاضراب الذي يستمر حتى
نهايه الشهر الجاري من جانبه اكد اتحاد
الخدمات العامه والتجاريه ان الاضطرابات
يمكن ان تستمر سته اشهر اذا لم تجلس
الحكومه الى طاوله المفاوضات تشارك في
اضرابات الجمعه عمال البريد الملكي
والعاملون في مراكز اختبار قياده السيارات
ضباط المرور في الطرق السريعه في لندن
وبعض اجزاء من انجلترا
من لندن ينضم الينا الان مراسله الجزيره
اسد الله الصاوي نرحب بك اسد الله يبدو ان
عدى الاضرابات تنتشر بشكل كبير في
بريطانيا كنا قد شهدنا وتابعنا معك ايضا
اضرب
طواقم الاسعاف والتمريض اليوم قطاع اخر
ينضم الى هذه الاضطرابات تفاصيل اليك
تتوسع وكل ما توسع الضيقت اكثر على
المواطنين البريطانيين الاضراب الابرز
اليوم هو اضراب ضباط الجوازات وامنع
الحدود في اكبر سته مطارات في
المملكه المتحده ومنها الاكثر ازدحاما على
الاطلاق في اوروبا وهو مطار هيرو في همم
لندن هذه المره همم الاضراب يتوقع ان يسبب
تاخيره في همم الرحلات وفي اجراءات
الجوازات حتى الان لم نبلغ باي الغاء لاي
رحلات ولكن هناك ميزه كبيره تقف الى جانب
الحكومه في هذه النقطه بالتحديد وهي وجود
البوابات الالكترونيه التي استثمر فيها
بريطانيا منذ سنوات طويله يعني اموالا
كثيره وهذا يسمح بمرور
المسجلين في همم بريطانيا على النظام
الامن في بريطانيا
الى ضباط الجوازات ل ايضا اضراب عمال
البريد وطبعا هذا له اهميه خاصه بالتزامن
مع موسم الاعياد الهدايا لا تصل بطاقات
المعايده لا تصل لاصحابها في المواد ربما
تصل بعد ذلك بشهر ولدينا ادراك
خاصه
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يقول بانه مستاء
بسبب الفوضى التي سببتها موجه الاضرابات
وبان الوضع الاوضاع صعبه ولكن افضل ما
يمكن ان نقوم به لمصلحه البلاد هو محاربه
همم التضخم هل من بوادر ربما لمفاوضات
الاحتواء الموقف
مما قلتي الان ازهار يبدا ان الحكومه
ثابته على موقفها لابد من الاشاره هنا الى
ان رئيس الوزراء ريشه هناك كان في حكومه
برج جونسون هو وزير الخزانه وبالتالي هو
يعلم مفاتيح الاموال ويعلم من اين يمكن ان
تاتي واين يمكن ان تنفق هذا الرجل حتى
الان واعضاء حكومته لم يبدو اي مرونه في
التفاوض مع موجه الاضطرابات والنقابات يجب
الاشاره هنا ازدهار كذلك الى ان موجه
اضرابات يعني عارمه مثل التي نشدها الان
في شتاء عام
1979 هي التي اتت ماركت المراه الحديديه
الى سده الحكم في بريطانيا وقد قامت
بتشريع عده قوانين قياده كثيره من قدره
النقابات على الاضراب وعلى املاء شروطهم
على الحكومات المختلفه همم لعبه عض
الاصابع تبدو مستمره حتى الان بين الحكومه
وبين النقابات وفي هذا الوقت يستمر
المواطن في المعركه شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
مراسل الجزيره اسد الله السامي شكرا لك